how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu
and thank you to everybody who wished me
luck or sent kind words to me in regards
to my surgery of course
the one day that i have surgery sony and
marvel decide to drop the official title
for spider-man 3 something we've been
waiting for
for over a year now but spider-man no
way home is our official title and i do
have some thoughts about this
specifically in regards to the timing of
the release of the official title and
not to mention all of the clues
on that white whiteboard that was shown
to us during tom holland's video
that combined with new photos from
spider-man 3 that were officially
released by tom holland and the fact
that kevin feige the president of marvel
studios did confirm
that one division is going to connect
directly to spider-man
no way home lead me to believe that
there could be a big
reveal coming up in one division episode
8 or for the finale
in regards to how this all connects to
spider-man directly
because they confirmed that one division
actually takes place before the events
of spider-man far from home so how does
one division connect to spider-man
no way home which is going to take place
even more down the line
well first and foremost let's talk about
the timing of the release of the
official title for spider-man 3
no way home they released it kind of
right at the peak of the one division
series we only have two episodes left
and we had a huge reveal last episode so
why release the official title
now why not wait till after the series
has ended well it would make sense that
they would release the official title
now because it
actually has something to do with what's
about to happen in the one division
series
now when they released the official
title on the whiteboard there were a
bunch of different names that were
potential names for spider-man
no way home
and as i think many of you know i've
been pitching for spider-man home worlds
which they wrote out and marked
boring which i think is actually a
pretty good joke on all of us who were
predicting spider-man homeworlds and
they wrote boring as a joke because
obviously
a spider-man movie that's going to
involve three different spider-man and
possibly even more
is not going to be boring at all which
kind of leads me to believe that they're
kind of trying to throw us off a little
bit and that's actually
what's happening but again the spider
verse has not yet been confirmed
just heavily hinted at and of course we
have reports from insiders who have been
right about a lot of things in the past
so we'll have to wait and see
but ironically enough there are hexagons
all over this board
now this could be another joke by marvel
studios and sony because they know that
we're looking
way deep into one division around these
hexagons that have been popping up
everywhere but to me it does seem like
this is actually a connection
because if we take a step back and look
at everything as a whole everything does
seem to connect
one division is going to go directly
into doctor strange and the multiverse
of mandus but before
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness comes out we are going to get
spider-man no way home
in which doctor strange is confirmed to
be in then as i mentioned kevin feige
did say
one division will connect directly into
spider-man no way home so they truly are
connected but what is the actual
connection well it has to be
the multiverse so it seemed like this
white board was kind of trying to tell
us that hey
look spider-man 3 is not going to really
be about a multiverse film
but at the same time it kind of has to
be because that's what one division is
setting up and one division goes into
spider-man no way home
now again the fact that there is a hex
and actually a few hexes on this board
point us to the connection between
spider-man no way home and one division
so
what is that connection well i believe
that at the end of one division she is
going to break open the multiverse and
this will start the events of no way
home
and there actually is an easter egg
reference in spider-man
far from home that backs up this theory
in spider-man far from home nick fury
and maria hill or should i say talos and
his wife
when talking with mysterio and tom
holland spider-man trying to explain
what is happening they say
that mysterio is from a different
universe and they mentioned the
multiverse
now this would ultimately end up to be
not true mysterio was lying
however they believed him talos and his
wife who are incredibly intelligent
beings believe mysterio about the
multiverse and this is most likely
because the events of one division
bursted open
more evidence of this at the end was the
fact that jay jonah jameson the same
one from the daily bugle and the
original spider-man trilogy was now in
the marvel cinematic universe
white cast the same exact person to play
the same exact character if it's not
going to be from that same universe
this is evidence that the multiverse
truly is present
in spider-man far from home and is going
to be in spider-man no way home
so what could we see from one division
that's going to lead us towards
spider-man far from home and eventually
no way home well i believe that we could
get something in a post
credit scene we're already going to be
getting that big secret cameo in episode
8 or
9. it shouldn't be a post-credit scene
because paul bettany talked about
working with this person and he talked
about how well they worked together and
how they clicked so it's obviously not
going to be for a post-credit scene
because it's going to be for a scene
or scenes much longer than that but
marvel does a great way of setting up
future films in post-credit scenes this
is what they do
and yes one of vision leads into doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
but first has to come spider-man no way
home
so it actually makes sense that juan
division's post credit scene could be
about spider-man and if we take a look
at one of the photos from
spider-man no way home that tom holland
released it actually looks like peter mj
and ned are actually in
doctor strange's sanctum and in another
photo we can see that the three of them
are looking up at
a person and we can actually see that
person's shadow
this is most likely doctor strange since
he is confirmed to have a role in
spider-man no way home as peter's
mentor now of course we could speculate
all day long that this could actually be
daredevil or it could be toby maguire
spider-man or andrew garfield spider-man
but i think given the fact that the
other photo
looks like all three of them are
actually in the sanctum it is most
likely doctor strange but if we look at
this photo it looks like the sanctum
is not really in good shape not really
quite sure what happened to it but we
can assume that there's going to be some
big villain
at the end of one division and there
have been a lot of rumors and reports
that doctor strange will show up in one
division so we know we have agatha
harkness and we know that she's not
going to be working alone she has the
darkhold book and she's taken
wanda's twins she clearly has plans and
it seems like those plans are to summon
an even greater villain this could be
chathan mephisto
nightmare any one of those and all of
which are actually dr strange's
responsibility not to mention as you may
have caught in one of my last videos it
looks like agatha harkness took
the darkhold from the sanctum from
doctor strange and wong so he's most
likely going to be looking for agatha
because of the darkhold book as well
plus i'm sure he senses what is
happening with wanda so if doctor
strange shows up in one division that's
another reason why the post credit scene
may not
actually be for doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness it would make
sense that the post-credits scene would
actually be doctor strange and maybe
wanda with him
interacting with tom holland spider-man
and possibly since the multiverse will
be a part of it maybe even more
spider-man
i think this would be the perfect way to
tease the connection between all three
movies and possibly even tease the
spider-verse if they decided to throw
another spider-man in there and what
better way to promote wanda vision than
to have an insane
post-credit scene like that in it and
then at the end of spider-man far from
home they can do a post-credits scene
setting up
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness which will involve doctor
strange wanda
and of course the multiverse i
personally think that there's a high
possibility that this could be what
we're going to get i think it makes a
lot of sense for marvel to go down this
route
but let me know what you all think about
this theory in the comments down below
again who do you think that secret cameo
is going to be what villain do you think
i got the hardness is going to summon
and what do you think we'll see in the
post-credits scene
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and of course don't
forget to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest one division or
spider-man news again i want to say
thank you all so much from the bottom of
my heart for everybody who was offering
their thoughts their prayers their kind
words to me yesterday when i had my
surgery
thanks for showing chris some love in
the video that he did and yes i will be
doing a watch party tonight so you can
join me here on my channel about 15 to
10 minutes before one of vision actually
starts we can all watch together if you
have disney plus
for live updates you can always follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much
for watching woof